jahrelang haben sich an diesem
bahnübergang im nordrhein-westfälischen
bad berleburg lastwagen immer wieder
festgefahren
der grund der neue übergang war falsch
konstruiert 800.000 euro zum fenster
rausgeschmissen
so richtig teuer und ärgerlich wurde es
auch für die lkw-fahrer mussten einmal
nachts mitten in der nacht ein fahrzeug
abladen der hatte noch fahrzeuge drauf
und er hat sich so verteilen entschieden
dass er nicht mehr weiterfahren konnte
und obwohl der fehler schnell erkannt
war passierte jahrelang gar nix 2017
reagiert die bahn dann doch die
landstraße wird abgesenkt und der
bahndamm um satte 80 zentimeter
angehoben
zusätzliche kosten rund eine million
euro
und oh wunder nach sage und schreibe
fünf jahren ist der bahnübergang
gefahrlos befahrbar endlich ja wir sind
sehr froh dass es fertig ist das hat
zwar lange gedauert aber wir waren uns
die autos nicht mehr kaputt und sich
alles verkehrt fertig ist nun auch die
alte brücke in dresden aber schön ist
anders denn beim umbau wurde hinter das
ein meter hohe historische gelände ein
zweites geklatscht
der grund die sicherheitsvorschriften
verlangen eine mindesthöhe von einem
meter dreißig damit fahrradfahrer nicht
in die elbe fallen für viele dresdner
eine total absurde nummer
ich weiß nicht wer sich so etwas
ausdenkt das ist völlig daneben
das ganze hätte man völlig anders machen
können indem man das restliche gelände
von vornherein ersticke angehoben hätte
nicht in dresden hier wird für satte 800
6000 euro ein geländer für ein geländer
gebaut
apropos ihrer der radweg im bayrischen
mond über den wir im frühjahr 2017
berichtet haben sie fertig völlig
beknackt aus denn hat ein loch es
während der bauphase war es zu erahnen
jetzt ist der murks perfekt das passiert
also wenn eine kommune munter drauflos
baut bevor sie alle nötigen grundstücke
zusammen gekauft hat
besser lief sind bielefeld noch vor
wenigen wochen waren die anwohner der
brehmstraße stinksauer dass alle
parkplätze rigoros gestrichen wurden
plötzlich war hier eine autofreie zone
grund fürs parkverbot die straße war von
der stadt zu schmal gebaut worden
es fehlten sage und schreibe zwei
zentimeter das kann ja wohl nicht wahr
sein können ja nicht einfach schilder
aufstellen und parkverbot hier hinsetzen
absolutes halteverbot unmöglich wie
gesagt ich habe morgens und abends ein
pflegedienst und die wissen nicht wo sie
den wagen hinstellen sollen nach dem
länderspiegel beitrag ist die verwaltung
doch noch mal in sich gegangen das
ergebnis wenn nur auf einer seite
geparkt wird ist genug platz für
rettungsfahrzeuge nach dem hammer der
woche kam ein mitarbeiter der stadt
haben die parkplätze ausgemessen und
markiert und eine woche später wurden
dann die gelben striche aufgeklebt so
dass wir unsere parkplätze fast alle
wieder haben in der bremer straße hoffen
die anwohner nun dass daraus wieder eine
dauerlösung wird und die gelben streifen
endgültig zu waisen werden